were you signing [ __ ] at 13
ryan dude you're probably saying [ __ ] at
eight yeah at eight
yeah it was it was crazy because like
dude i started competing when i was
seven
and um you know from there i really
realized how much i enjoyed competing
um it was super scary to me but it was
also like
this mental it was like a mental
challenge to overcome
the nerves that i was feeling i guess
and dude before contest i would i would
have to go behind the ramps and i would
like cry
because i was so nervous and it wasn't
because i didn't want to be there it was
just because i like
cared so damn much and yeah from that
point on dude it was just like
kept moving up in the ranks in the
california amateur skateboarding league
and then
one the uh one factory this like factory
division which was like the sponsored
division when i was 12 and then that got
me invited
to x games and slam city jam and the
vans triple crown and i think there was
one more like gravity games
and that year of 13 man i won every
single pro
contest and i only won man because i was
having fun there was no expectations
there was nothing on my mind
except for i was just a stoked little
kid
that got the opportunity to go skate
with the best dudes that i looked up to
and it just worked out you know it just
worked out i couldn't fall
it was weird you're saying you won every
pro contest when you were 13. yeah every
pro contest that there was
uh the 13th year of my life um
[Laughter]
which was champions 2003 that's the only
one
that's the only one i didn't get invited
to because i tampo
tampa was weird about you had to be pro
to be in the tampa pro and so i skated
tampa am earlier that year because it's
like the first contest of the year
and uh didn't do very well and then
ended up winning
all the pro contests epic dude
yeah dude